[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
newly uncovered posts made by an online
Forum may give us insight into Brian
coburger's character when he was a
teenager the man accused of killing four
University of Idaho students posted on a
forum dedicated to a condition known as
visual snow he wrote in part I feel like
an organic sack of meat with no
self-worth as I hug my family I look
into their faces I see nothing it is
like I am looking at a video game but
less visual snow syndrome is a disorder
where someone sees static in more than
100 posts between 2009 and 2012 coburger
reportedly wrote that visual snow led to
anxiety poor self-image and quote crazy
thoughts these Revelations come as
coburger's public defender pours through
Discovery preparing for a preliminary
hearing this summer so far police have
only named co-burger as a suspect
investigators pointing to evidence like
cell phone tower of pings an eyewitness
and DNA at the Idaho scene but there are
questions about what in information
Moscow police may have had before they
got the warrants that led to those
discoveries if defense counsel were able
to show police had little to go on
everything that came after could be in
Jeopardy long crime correspondent Angela
Levy spoke with the former attorney of
Scott Peterson on a recent episode of
our podcast sidebar she says poking
holes is a good strategy to have
yes you have to look at everything
altogether which is what the prosecution
is going to do they're going to say
you've got this piece you've got that
piece put them all together my goodness
that's a very strong circumstantial
evidence but our job as criminal defense
attorneys is to break it up break it
apart and start attacking every single
piece separately and show the jury or
the court in a prelim
the issues the unreliability of that
evidence and for example the shoes the
shoe prints very common right a bushy
eyebrows my goodness that's pretty
common if you ask me most men are gonna
fall under that category how do you
narrow down the group of suspects if
you're saying bushy eyebrows that's not
enough to identify and ID anyone so yes
there are some issues here
we know that insanity is not a defense
to murder in Idaho but do you think that
coburger may try to claim that his
visual disorder somehow impaired his
reasoning well if I were his defense
attorney I would definitely try to claim
that I don't think it's going to Prevail
though I mean you're right in Idaho you
absolutely don't have the insanity
defense but if he tries to say that he
was mentally impaired and he could not
tell the difference between right and
wrong he didn't have the men's Raya the
intent there then I think they could
possibly come up with some sort of
Defense but this new illness this snow
Vision illness I think unless they can
show that it makes people think
differently he's not going to be able to
succeed yeah I don't know much about
that syndra but definitely got to dig
into it Jesse do you see any issue with
how the police obtained evidence against
coburger well it's not clear but I think
it's something that his defense
attorneys should explore look for a
search warrant you need probable cause
if we go back to the affidavit there's
only a few mentions of a search warrant
they obtained a search warrant to get
all the cellular devices that were
connecting to the tower near the crime
scene in fact Brian Coburg her cell
phone didn't ping at the time of the
killings but they said as a result of
that it looked like he might have turned
his phone off from there they got a
second search warrant that actually
looked at his cell phone records and we
all know that there was some
questionable movements of his cell phone
but when it came to the car evidence
when it came to the DNA I didn't see
anything about a search warrant does
that mean that they applied for it and
it just they didn't mention it in the
affidavit did they not get a search
warrant it's not entirely clear but I
think it's definitely something that's
going to be explored by the defense yeah
what came from the search warrant seems
pretty damning but the question is what
probable cause do they have to get those
warrants and kind of brings them